may the best [ __ ] win I'm here repping
the queen of rap nicki manaj i'm here
repping the one-and-only multi-talented
mariah
i'm here repping mother monster lady
gaga and i'm here repping the bee hi
baby Beyonce
I feel like beyonce is the only one that
does have a look God guys like super
manufactured I mean just throw some meat
on it honey the only thing that Mariah
ever had as a good outfit was that
butterfly top in early 2000 and then
would happen
Eden's Crush wore it and it was done as
far as Nikki Nikki was like a bootleg
Gaga like she should go sit down the
Queen Bee has continued to slay I mean
she's we're talking about like the Met
Gala were you all even invite Raya is
always dressed for the God honey
gown flawless hair I got one point let
me just okay look yeah what's going on
with you like Lady gaga
okay yeah hey whoa okay all of those
outfit they mean something to her crazy
she dress in that in that state because
she was talking about equality and
saying that it was the prime rib sure
it's a crazy message but it got people
to look at her and that's what she's
using her fame for okay my turn I nobody
care about what you wear irrelevant no
the most like the finding characteristic
of Nick Morales look isn't always has
been dead-ass though and like that was
what the whole anaconda thing revolved
overhang class you know should she cover
up her booty yeah woman OH
I clearly win that hello Miley what's
good Oh Eileen what's gonna deesis
ratchet like isn't a problem act out but
like we called Nikki ratchet anyways cuz
like cuz like by that we're just being
like oh she's not like a white like
fancy artist that wears gowns
I think Mariah's ratchet behind the
scenes like she doesn't give you ratchet
in your face right it's on a bad thing
I'm a little ratchet everybody oh [ __ ]
I'm [ __ ] ranch I wrote the book on
right I've seen her over the weekends I
know she is yeah I'm gonna say Mariah's
probably like the most like attitude old
diva out there for sure
I feel like Beyonce and Mariah are like
icons at this point Gaga's you know
caught working her way up there crawling
crawling the thing about Niki's diva
attitude is that she busts it out for
the sake of saying something that
matters she took a big hit when she
called out Miley like that
everyone was like who's this savage
ratchet-ass black woman attacking this
like put a little white girl right on my
own right like people said that about
her and like okay yeah she's got an
attitude and yeah she tore her to pieces
but for good reasons
mariah is the epitome of talent darling
18 number-one countless awards remember
Glee doubtless award remembered when I
remember glitter anyone's out-of-date
this one oh are you a dungeon dragon
Nicki Minaj's the queen of rep last year
has to be ET award she was given artists
the Year award
she threw some mad shade at a key it
seems like she's always throwing shade
at people throwing mad shade because
there's a lot of gum as culturally
appropriating white girls running around
so Lady Gaga writes her own songs she
designs her own show she used to design
her all of her own costumes Beyonce is
just the most talented being on the
planet she um
rocked the Super Bowl without any sort
of props she didn't have little dancing
sharks or little beach balls miss Katy
Perry she didn't need like other like
guest star Kelly and Michelle I mean
Michelle kind of failed
you mean her backup dancers came no I
don't get drunk and watched [ __ ] like
The Sound of Music I get drunk and I
wanna sleep but y'all say I divas
wouldn't want us fighting we would
collaborate with each other um I will
say that I do listen to each and every
single one of these girls every single
one on my Spotify they all that they'll
get icons